un forum de la mobilité pour venir à la
rencontre des usagers des transports en
commun à thales le 21 septembre
plusieurs stands d'information était
installé dans les locaux objectif
associer le personnel de l'entreprise
pour améliorer le réseau de saint
quentin en yvelines ça leur permet
d'avoir vraiment une relation de
proximité
d'avoir vraiment l'impression en tant
qu'utilisateur que les sociétés de
transport sont à leur écoute et vraiment
ils peuvent discuter un moment au calme
dans un élément convivial de leurs
besoins trois partenaires ski bus pour
tous les skis sont venus présenter leur
ligne et leur projet avec ce forum
thales espère favoriser l'utilisation
des transports en commun auprès de ses
3000 collaborateurs
j'ai pas eu d'usagé l'air donc justement
je me dis peut-être que ça devrait être
l'occasion de s'y mettre j'emprunte
souvent les transports en commun donc la
ligne 15 et puis ça tombe bien la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et présentent
donc c'est pour leur faire part
d'éventuelles suggestions également me
renseigner au niveau des horaires une
initiative menée dans le cadre de la
semaine de la mobilité à saint quentin
en yvelines la communauté
d'agglomération a également mis en place
une enquête en ligne pour restructurer
son réseau de bus tous les habitants des
douze communes du territoire sont
invités à y répondre jusqu'au 15 octobre